I think it's fair to say that you and
Victor approach basketball in very
different ways the style of play the way
you just play both offense and defense
what what do you think about his game
overall and have you thought about how
these battles could be going on for a
long time between you
two Victor is a very special player uh
we were just talking about in the locker
room he's a dude that can get two or
three defensive player of the years and
also I don't want to put no limit on it
but he can get defensive player years
and
MVPs uh cuz
that we haven't seen nothing like that
we've seen things close but not like
that I mean he's an amazing player and I
think especially with pop over there he
going to continue to develop you said
you said you were aware of where he was
on that last play are you kind of
looking behind you sneaking a peak or
cuz he came from behind didn't he oh
yeah uh I mean you you got to be aware
of stuff like that I mean like I said he
got the block shot on me two players
before and I thought I had the layup so
I mean in a situation like that I just
got to be aware of where everybody's
at